on va jouer just as juste calories ses
gammes le juste prix le principe est
sympa que devoir deviner quel plat parmi
les propositions affichées est moins
calorique qu'une pizza margherita
marguerite à wil à 1 270 calories ok
mais attention il ya une mauvaise
réponse évidemment tout est calculé pour
des proportions de 100 grammes
vous allez devoir éliminer à chaque fois
une réponse d'accord on va démarrer par
frédéric frédéric quel plat parmi les
propositions affichées est moins
calorique qu'une pizza margherita
sénégal où rim ont dansé chi sushi c'est
une bonne réponse bien sûr 170 calories
c'est une bonne réponse bravo et oui je
croyais que les sushis c'est des sushis
c'est bien ou pas c'est bien mais des
foyers durer un peu vinaigrée un peu ça
crée donc un petit peu mais pas trop les
sushis le soir il faut éviter ou pas
voilà le soir c'est parce qu'après on va
dormir ne peut pas faire forcément
d'activité physique mais un petit de
temps en temps voilà faut se faire
plaisir mais pas trop tout le temps non
plus d'accord t'as merci raymond allez
on prend quoi moi je prends le boeuf
bourguignon
mais laissez-moi 172 calories très
bonnes réponses
2 vraiment bravo raymond a vraiment
attention philippe lellouche couscous
royal
bravo très bonnes réponses en 49
calories secousse royal le couscous
royal c'est pas si calorique que ça oui
ça dépend ce qu'on y met dedans ce n'est
pas aussi les quantités qu'on en mange
d'accord c'est ça mais moi en fait moi
ouais en fait j'ai il vient de dire un
truc qui me concerne ce que moi c'est ce
point que des trucs pas très caloriques
mais bien oui je prends me plaire
forcément à un moment tu te dis bon
c'est tu vois franchement et les faces
bout de voile à jour 1 alors qu'un peu
regard il faut pas s'interdire non plus
d'en manger
mais si on essaie d'avoir un rythme un
régime de vie sain le week-end c'est
bien la place à le cheat mills et le
fameux petit mil du samedi soir c'est ça
le tube faire plaisir à l'époque on
pouvait sortir dans les restaurants est
normalement une fois par semaine le type
me voilà exactement ont fait six fois
sur sept le cheap mais si tu me laisser
il faut s'appliquer c'est compliqué mais
et moi on peut sans un peu on peut se
faire un vous faites une fois par
semaine un kiff une fois par semaine ou
de temps en temps ça dépend aussi la
dose de sport que vous faites dans la
journée
mais voilà il faut savoir qu
alimentation faut pas qu'on puisse se
priver trop d'accord voilà faut y aller
étape par étape j'adore est il me faut à
qui dois je prends à périgueux le départ
c'est bon allez on continue avec
isabelle il dirait la nuit là où ya
baisse très bonne réponse d'isabelle 106
calories seulement la bouillabaisse
berkshire benjamin castaldi éviter de
manger vous voulez c'est très très peu
106 kg à l'horizon la bouillante sida
c'est de la soupe et poissons si je vous
dis donc bouillabaisse c'est bien
qu'elle ait le repas voilà si on devait
faire le matin le midi et le soir repas
idéal alors un bon petit déjeuner un bon
petit déjeuner pardon je dirais des
flocons d'avoine pour voir une source de
glucides
je dirais des protéines comme des oeufs
c'est génial pourquoi pas du lait
végétal le matin moi j'ai toujours mon
petit thé vert le matin plutôt du chaos
c'est un petit thé vert qui passe bien
et après le midi
dury pourquoi pas ou des pâtes complets
de la dengue des légumes à volonté qu
importe jusqu'à maintenant il faut jure
que c'est vrai allez-y ce matin j'ai
mangé un meilleur hockey et j'ai mangé
ce matin du chocolat comme ça un gâteau
au chocolat
ah c'est pas toi tu as déjà pour
commencer par ses crèches aller manger
chez ma mère ce midi je vous jure que
c'est vrai j'ai mangé du thon au green
de terre ok bien skier alors j'ai pour
juste qu'on a peut être là mourir parce
que c'est ma mère ya toujours un gars
tunisien jour que c'est vrai c'est un
plat j'aime parce qu'être d'hommes il y
avait des merguez
c'est un truc 0 break c'est un plat qui
ne finit jamais au 10 mai ce qu'en fait
c'est tellement c'est que de la sauce
comme ça que de l'huile est déçu car il
y à sa nuit en fête et un truc noir
dedans et à chaque fois que manger comme
lui elle repart sur le plateau à la
personne n'a pas bronché et donc j'ai
mangé ça ok mais j'ai mangé ce qu'on
appelle un boy scout ou en dessert c'est
un gâteau comme à 4 car les tunisiens
c'est à dire avec plus d huile que deux
cartes
je suis bien où je peux m'arrêter moi
c'est sûr c'est un peu beaucoup c'est un
peu beaucoup le début comment c'est bien
le ton pomme de terre c'est très bien et
après voilà c'est parti
tiens c'est sans merci
tu connais cette histoire de la jeune
mariée qui est qui qui vient de se
marier
le soir le type rendre chez elle le
premier jour de boulot et de vie commune
et il voit sa femme avec l'huile d'olive
au dessus de la casserole comme ça il
fait qu'est ce que tu fais mon amour
elle dit je sais pas encore si
l'étudiant c'est ça la merde façon
peut-être un mollet déjà le soir la
bouteille d'huile
je me suis un jour il y avait pas de
l'huile à la maison mes parents je suis
rentré c'est comme ça et s'est assis sur
un canapé dans y'a pas de piles et du
pain
menés 3 à la maison ils achètent des
gens atteints de noël mamère on va
manquer de passer un truc de fou ces
gens après deux saisons avec vous c'est
vous on cherche plus donc quelques tous
les to les uns des plats qui sont moins
calorique qu'une pizza de 270 qu'elle
repart valérie bénaïm là il reste que
des trucs un peu long je vais prendre ce
qui me semble moins lourde tout le steak
frites le steak frites c'est une bonne
réponse 244 calories
bien joué valérie bénaïm 244 calories
ils ont enlevé le kebab à mais c'est
juste à côté ils se sont trompés
un steak frites ça va de temps en temps
tu appareils le salaire c'est pas mal
il ya des steaks 5% qui sont top les
frites pareil doucement comme c'est à
dire doucement c'était une fois par
semaine trois frites 5,5 frites
non non non une assiette une assiette
voilà quand même toujours faire plaisir
mais et thibault tu sais que tu
m'angoisser ce soir il faut y aller
doucement au secours des frites cas du
sport tous les jours font avoir ces
mamans qua non franchement après tout
c'est quoi mais pas quand même beaucoup
de joie aussi elle si franchement si tu
faisais pas la pole et moi je pense que
je ferai en kg 150 kilotonnes
aujourd'hui c'est vrai parce que moi là
je dois faire franchement heureusement
je peux faire voilà va me 15 15 heures
par semaine ok c'est donc ça va non je
te jure que c'est vrai mais je turquie
parce que mais je mange mais comment
vous ce soir je sais trés note je vais
rentrer je vais me démonter frère
mais moi mais je tenais je suis
l'outremangeur vous pouvez à condition
voilà d'heureux de demain refaire du
sport à fond vous grignotez série
l'année scolaire s'est pas passé
reconnaît je sortais de chez ma mère je
suis arrivé dans la golf r j'ai mangé il
y avait 18 madeleine je les ai mangé du
chocolat avec des noisettes petits
partis une horreur je suis une horreur
alors on a quoi ensuite il avait déjà
parlé oui merci je suis très content
vous soyez la bible ou des baisses de
ces merci kebab ah bah oui parce qu'il
était déjà parti en bleu kebab alors
kebab moi tue moi je suis un fou de
kebabs
comment on fait quand on a à [ __ ]
kebap comme tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent et se lisent le kebab c'est la
vie quoi un mois une journée sans kebab
c'est comme une journée sans amour après
ça dépend les objectifs que vous avez un
en avoir des abdos
c'est bon grâce à la vidéo thibout je
sais pas si tu connais mais les
tunisiens sont pas d'abord peut
s'entraîner 8h30
mais mozilla la naissance mon frère il
ya un gars qui arrivait et dit toi tu
auras pas d'abord père tunisien qui on
lève son verre d abord faire ma voisine
frères des pauvres gars de même taille
avait été remplacé sur la plage en
tunisie frère bien sûr non mais si c'est
une barre qu'après vous n'êtes pas
tunisien alors vous avez des tablettes
de chocolat partout vous oui mais non
mais oui mais des frais tablette cache
et non mais comment on fait pour avoir
des abdos moi c'est le truc le plus dur
à travailler je ne travaille jamais les
abdos je peux pas alors ça va être
l'alimentation assez franchement à 60%
et après le sport que vous allez faire
est fait est juste bouger déjà bougé
fait du coup j'ai bougé comme les magic
system quand on voit exactement pareil
d'accord pas muscu du crossfit du cross
training voilà bouger même une demi
heure par jour sur le pont assez bon pas
stand up c'est très bien c'est super
gars bouger
ce serait bien possible la part d'ong
agim passive connaître les électrodes
well as moi je suis pas fan ces cas là
qui adore moi je suis pas fan suis
plutôt vieille école c'est à dire là les
pompes des beurs peas du squat et crs à
match canon le beurre puis c'est à dire
tu manges en mangeant une tartine de
beurre
le code-barres peas le beurre pis elles
nous montrent à l'évidence suis
tranquille parce que je vous montre et
il est vraiment sympathique
ça fait de jeter qui fait déjouer s'est
pas entraîné aujourd'hui ces enchères
aujourd'hui je vais pas te le dire mais
ça se voit je transpirais pas burpee
sein des mouvements c'est un des pires
mouvements d'europe vous jeter au sol
pour l'heure comme c'est ça le micro et
hop vous sautez remember pis ça passe 50
burpee ça passe plus trop ouais donc
donc voilà et ça c'est une tannée et ça
s'est passé jeudi ont des raisons bien
sûr
autorités jlm le fera bien dans ton nom
mais c'est tout alors le kebab ses 223
calories al qaîda est à venir c'est
bizarre on tournait toujours d'accord
que la pizza c'est plus caloriques que
tous savent que tout ça incroyable mois
qu'ils mangent
depuis trois pizzas par semaine c'est
chaud combien là ça dépend ce que vous
dites y'a laurine kleiza le kebab de son
camp le regard des sceptiques moins cinq
morts ces petits c 200 calories inquiet
par 200 g de ce que ça mais qui va
manger 100 g de kebab battu faut bien
écouter on n'a pas la chance d'avoir
voyagé travailler à lui nommé au marché
inquiet mais il fait pas cent grammes de
kebabs c'est vrai que c'est très rare
étaient minimes g dessous explique non
plus à vous jean michel maire alors il
reste le hamburger et la tarte à la
crème et le cassoulet kelly et le gamin
baker escales samedi c'est castaldi
alors il reste quoi alors là je suis sûr
de ma réponse contrairement à ce qu'on
peut penser le cassoulet n'est pas tant
qu'elle risque que ça c'est vrai ouais
mais ça fait péter les plombs ça qui s'y
connaît vous démarrez vous souhaite un
très bon bravo benjamin castaldi le
cassoulet exactement le cassoulet 116
calloway se serait fait le moins
calorique avec la bouillabaisse de tous
les noms alors ici mais si c'est ça
c'est bien ça fait surtout à 20 khz avec
modération tout est bon mais bon donc
non de temps en temps c'est la mecque
saleh ben voilà alors thibault tu nous
as dit pour le petit déjeuner ce qu'il
fallait donc pas d'y voir des oeufs des
flocons d'avoine dupagny complet
voilà un fruit un kiwi une banane corps
m'a quand même mangé le matin après à
midi à 12h du riz une viande blanche ou
viandes blanches ou jaunes l'oriental
est un légume légumes pouvons rien y
compris par l etat les légumes là et
après le soir on va dire du léger mais
en même temps un peu lucide avec
pareille du riz des flocons d'avoine
peut-être pas le soir on va augmenter
les flocons d'avoine sa phase iii soit
ça veut dire que le soir on peut réduire
un peu son apport glucidique sans appel
donc un peu moins de riz ou un peu moins
de patte toujours un petit peu et avec
une poisson par exemple un poisson blanc
du sommet non du ton et des légumes à
volants de têtu ont beaucoup de légumes
ouais ouais savez vous comment ta part
est taxé mais je t'aime bien mais c'est
pas moi qui m'étais dit a dit nadal fait
plaisir je te le dis tu viens quand tu
veux avec modération
thibault sur la tête de ma mère toi
c'est quoi son envie de faire à une
télé-réalité très brune chez ma mère et
transmirent et tête de ma mère il reste
[Rires]
sur des niches je change de métier c'est
ma mère mes frères et moi même une
journée j'ai pas être bien battant mais
je suis j'ai envie de la faire cette
exceptionnelle alléger le bateau répond
alors tarte à la crème rome le regard
est ce que voulait un petit indice
c'était parce que vous croyez mais
voulait pas mardi
tarte à la crème moins caloriques
colombien ouais je pense vous êtes sûr
non vous l'avez dit oui regardez-la 10
[Musique]
[Rires]
je garde
pour l'année